all right thank you done and I
appreciate Doug really introducing this
because we went from someone who's
directly into production Doug who's got
the extension background but what I
really appreciate is that he introduced
the idea of looking at the digestible
matter how the animal itself functions
and using that to inform what we're
going to be seeing in the Muar the
reason I say that is in my position here
at Carleton state I'm actually at
Hamilton Trish missed even though I do
have background in crop science of soil
science my primary function is as an
animal nutritionist so my talk on manure
comes from my training and nutrition but
then also a look at what happens within
the animal and how's that going to
inform the rest of this so my experience
of service comes from research I did one
on cattle but to coming up with a book
chapter talking about small ruminants
and other room animals and their manure
production for a book that the crop
science aside is about to release on
animal manure first one really introduce
you to the extent of management when it
comes to these animals the best
information out there when it comes to
what is it like to raise deer or rain
servants as a life subspecies comes out
of Texas a meal when they put together
of that publication we were looking at
about seventy eight hundred deer farms
across the United States and they
certainly had several the big four that
they discussed though or the
white-tailed deer the L the fallow deer
and the red deer and there's some
different management considerations that
go along with that now before it just
sounds like you know I'm using Texas A&M
betta I'm living in Texas before that
sounds like a Texas talk yes
if we look at the map the largest
concentration of farms do exist in the
state of Texas but it's not an isolated
incident if we look at the second-most
we've got to go over to the East Coast
you look at Pennsylvania and then
third-most we end up going up the
Minnesota so it is really more of a
national consideration not just an
isolated incident now one thing I'll
tell you is to wrap your head around
this you've got to
imagine what this farm looks like I'm
very much like Aaron some of the others
most of my background is in your more
traditional livestock so I imagine a
beef cattle operation but you have to
kind of change that imagination a little
bit when it comes to looking at the
raising of beer and of the other
servants usually we're dealing with very
small concentrations of animals with the
exception of fallow deer of you're going
to be split in roughly thirds you're
going to have a third of your population
dedicated bumail a third to the female
and a third to the offspring
balladeer a little different and what I
tribute this to is just the size of the
animal it's easier to have a lot more
animals existing but if you compare this
to most of our other livestock species
that's not a really big operation that
we're looking at in terms of the male so
it is a much different scenario and a
lot of that's got to deal with
management versus our other livestock
species if we take that management
operation so we take that idea of
management and try to translate it
moving into the farming characteristics
and then even into the animal manure
there are certain costs that are just
going to exist and we can take it from
the economics all the way down to the
manure if you look at this ikanai and
breakdown that came from that
publication about 40% of your costs are
going to be sunk in the capital 40%
operational there's not
I'm really much you're going to
categories like I said my background is
in nutrition so the one that I tend to
pay attention to its feed feed cost in
my view are the one thing that you can
look at that is a variable is something
that can be changed that you can look at
and it's going to more likely inform
what you're looking at on the manure
side again it would picture this
comparing it to other livestock we would
expect that farming of deer or farming
of servants would be more related to a
very extensive operation we will be
looking at wide open spaces this is
where I'm going to directly kind of be
your back cattle just like you have
cattle if you imagine the cow calf
scenario where you have more extensive
pastures where you got them roam more
freely freely and on time more of a
grazing type scenario that does exist
that's going to be more on the sporting
side of raising deer if you're looking
at the breeding side so just like our
other two presentations especially
alligators where you have the breeding
versus the raising the breeding
operations are going to look more like a
confined operation so we're going to be
imagining more of our bullet test or our
feedlot scenario now what are the
particulars when it comes to the
individual species well it really
depends on the mindset if you look at
the mindset when it comes to raising red
deer or elk the primary reason that
these animals are raised has to do with
a consumer demand for healthy meat
alternatives and when I say healthy
understand that I'm saying a consumer
demand for a leaner meat source a leaner
meat source compared to beef let's say
when you're looking at these animals the
other thing to consider and it's with
all of these species these species are
suited to land that we can't necessarily
attribute to directly to crop production
or even to raising our other livestock
species and that's because these animals
are considered to be browsers if we
classify our eminent animals and
classify these of browsers that means
that they survive on marginal land
they're able to consume
things that we would not feed their
other livestock I'm not going to send
cattle out expect them to browse all
leaves off of trees or bark off trees
where these animals would so their
suitability for marginal land really
sets the most refer from some of those
key areas where we can't get a lot of
other agricultural production we shift
our mindset a little bit when it comes
to the white-tailed deer and that's
because the whitetail is not so much a
focus on healthy meat offer news but
more a focus on the sporting aspect
we're looking at operation of hunting
rancher so we've got some ranches that
are going to focus solely on breeding
those animals selecting four of the
marketable characteristics and then
we're going to have operations that are
just going to focus on trying to market
them to the consumer so marketing guided
hunts now I've spent a lot of time
talking about management
it sounds like I'm teaching a production
class of deer and that's really not
where I'm going I want to set you in
that mindset of what's happening on
these operations because as we look at
raising the animal that's going to
inform what happens with the manure and
this is where I get them uh point that
expression of the manure nutrients is
going to revolve around two things two
identifiable things that we can look at
and that we can change what is going to
be diet composition and the other is
diet digestibility those are both things
that we can control when it comes to
raising these animals because as we
shift that composition so will we shift
that digestibility putting together data
for this we start to look at what is
typical of these animals and I'm going
to split them out just like I hit on the
management side and talk about the red
deer and the elk versus the white-tailed
deer if we look at the red deer and elk
we're looking at their intake and
they're going to be consuming somewhere
around five percent of their body weight
a day although while they're consuming
of that five percent about half of it is
going to be digestible so we focus
really on these two numbers and then
when it comes to what we're concerned
about with a manure either on how do we
handle that
Anouar or how is it distributed this
becomes our other big one we're looking
at what's the digestibility of crude
protein than that maneuver so instead of
just throwing some numbers at you I want
to give you an illustration let's go
through an example let's say that we're
working with Red Deer we're going to
assume that that deer weighs about 440
pounds all right I said the first thing
that we could effect was the diet so
we're gonna look at the forage they
consume while we're I told you about how
much they consume so of this we say that
that 440 pound animal is going to
consume 6.2 pounds of dry matter now if
we're looking at fresh forage that's
going to be about 13 pounds of fresh
forage but when we're looking at all
this we've got to stay on the dry matter
number to keep things eat if we take
that then and look at the digestibility
our little poop emoji tells us that we
end up with two point nine pounds of dry
matter in the feces that's just giving
an expression of that 52% by disability
so this is per animal per day if we're
dealing with a confined operation that
could tend to build up over time if
we're looking at extensive operation so
more of a pasture based system that's
not as big of a concern but let's look
more into the characteristics of that
manure let's say that the forage that
they're consuming this is marginal land
so we're going to be low crude protein
we're going to be under 8% so by seven
and a half percent we then know with the
crude protein digestibility that manure
is going to come out we've got point
three one pounds of crude protein makes
it through the animal into the manure so
we can now characterize that manure that
maneuver is now going to be 1.6 percent
nitrogen and that's going to be a very
similar to a lot of our livestock
species where we already use their
manures it's fertilizer the difference
is going to be that we're dealing with a
much drier maneuver and with a being
much drier that gives us a lot of
opportunity if this maneuver is
collected so if we're in the breeding
operations where the examples are in
confinement that gives us a lot of
opportunity that can exist there the
reason I go through all of this I don't
want to give you some comparisons
it depends but it's not a servant
operation what you're doing if we look
at the white-tailed deer we've got a
completely different scenario their
intake is roughly the same we're within
a half percent of body weight or 0.8
percent of body weight digestibility
roughly the same so I wouldn't consider
these two numbers to be that unusual
those are nearly consistent across the
board when it comes to serving a
livestock what I want to point out
though is the crude protein
digestibility research that has been
done on these species on the feeding
side shows that white-tailed deer are
much more efficient at nitrogen at
nitrogen utilization so let's go through
the same scenario let's take our
white-tailed deer at 125 pounds so
smaller animal with it being a smaller
animal we already know it's going to
consume less so we're going to cut our
consumption down from six pounds to two
pounds cut it in 1/3 with that
digestibility we end up with one pound
dry matter extrusion now this becomes a
manageable number whether we're
extensive or Ian tenses this is a number
that we can deal with and we're not
going to have a manure buildup as
quickly
the interesting thing comes though in
crude protein that same forage that we
would have fed the red deer and we would
have ended up with a manure that was 1.6
percent nitrogen now we've got a manure
that's 1 percent nitrogen we're able to
use this manure more extensively lower
nitrogen concentration yes it means that
you're not getting as much bang for the
buck when it comes to manure nutrients
but you're also not limited as much on
how much can be applied I take you
through these calculations because if we
look at what's publishing the literature
I'm going to echo Doug on this one
those'll saying that there's really not
much out there on manure characteristics
of alligators his was none my talk is
not necessarily nothing we did have some
but to say it's limited as an understate
there's one thing that Aaron brought up
the other day when she and I were
talking about this there's zero
information out there about deer urine
and we all know that when
comes to the total nutrient management
prospect that urine can have a big
impact especially when we talk about
nitrogen relations but if we're just
leaving manure characteristics I take
you through that because it illustrates
where we're getting these numbers we
were able to calculate that one to two
percent nitrogen that was going to
appear in the manure we were able to
account for that load or the high dry
matter percentage low moisture in the
feces so it's just a way to illustrate a
time together of that relationship
between feeding the animal and managing
the app and that concludes my talk on
servings I believe now I turn it back
over to Aaron